As conservatives, we know
that getting an abortion
is as easy as getting a cab
in New York City.
Cab!
Roe v. Wade has resulted
in some of the most permissive
abortion laws
anywhere in the world.
Do you want abortion on demand?
-Abortion on demand...
Yet somehow
the liberals complain
that we've gotten in the way
of their abortion on demand,
and now they won't stop talking
about the state of Mississippi.
While you weren't looking,
the governor of Mississippi
is trying to make his state
the hardest place in America
to get an abortion.
Now we don't have access
to safe and legal
abortion services.
Clearly Republicans
are trying to take us back
to the days when women died
from unsafe abortions
in this country.
GREY: Time to fly south
to expose these lies.
So we came to the only Planned
Parenthood in Mississippi
to show you just how easy it is
to get an abortion.
In what's sure to be
The Opposition's
shortest field piece ever.
-All right.
-(both grunting)
Shouldn't have packed
all these Bibles.
Hey. So, we'd like
two abortions, please.
-Two abortions now.
-Yeah.
Here in Mississippi,
the landscape
-that the politicians
have created -Uh-huh.
have made it so difficult
that places
like our health centers
can't provide a full range
of services.
-Okay, I feel like that was
a very loaded no. -Yeah.
That's correct.
THURMAN: So, according to
Planned Parenthood's Staci Fox,
this clinic
doesn't offer abortions.
GREY:
But why?
States are introducing
more bills
to prevent access to care.
Right here in Mississippi,
the state legislature
passed a bill
banning abortion at 15 weeks.
I think these laws are tactics
to start to chip away
access to what
the Roe v. Wade decision set
as the legal standard
in the United States.
THURMAN: If Mississippi has made
it so hard to get abortions,
how come there's a clinic
right next door?
GREY: So we infiltrated what was
obviously an abortion provider
based on the fact
that their website
clearly targets
people seeking abortions.
We don't do abortions,
and we don't refer
for abortions.
-(record scratches)
-BOTH: Wait, what?
The building next door
is a fake women's health center,
and these centers
that exist all over the country
provide women
distorted information
and often
inaccurate information.
That is, like, the worst prank
but, like, the best prank.
It's like Jackass but for your
reproductive rights.
THURMAN:
In Mississippi, there are more
of these fake
women's health centers,
aka crisis pregnancy centers,
than there are Starbucks.
But it's still so easy.
If you're a woman who wanted
to access abortion care
in the state of Mississippi,
unfortunately,
you'll have to drive
to Jackson, Mississippi.
THURMAN: Okay, there's only
one clinic left in Mississippi.
You know what that means.
BOTH:
Road trip!
GREY: And who could possibly
have a problem
with a road trip?
Imagine if you were a woman
who had a job
GREY:
I don't. Show's canceled.
Or needed to put the children
that you had at home
in childcare.
THURMAN:
Ew, I don't have kids.
And the financial resources
to drive 100 miles.
THURMAN: We're rich, Staci.
Quit playing.
The 100 mile trip
from Hattiesburg to Jackson
flew by.
GREY: And just imagine,
some lucky ladies
get to have
an even longer road trip.
Now that we've made it
to the state's
only abortion clinic,
we can show you how easy it is
to get abortions on demand.
THURMAN: As soon as we get past
a few brave protesters.
We are here for the gospel
of Jesus Christ.
I would absolutely
counsel people
that the Lord says
all fornicators
have their place
in the lake of fire.
And so we are here crying out
for people to consider
that we stand before
a holy and righteous god.
You want to go back
to when abortion was illegal
and no one had abortions.
-Oh, wait.
-They had them.
But they were illegal
and dangerous
-and they died.
-People were dying. Yeah.
GREY: After making it past
this guy and his sound logic...
Well, it's no different
than at the Holocaust.
...we could finally go inside
with the help
of a clinic escort
protecting women
from protesters.
What a breeze.
THURMAN: After that,
we could finally talk
to Shannon Brewer,
the clinic's director,
about how getting an abortion
was so freaking easy.
No, it's not... it's not
that easy to get an abortion.
Um, you have to call,
schedule an appointment.
GREY:
To get your abortion on demand,
all you need is an appointment.
Then...
You have to speak with
a counselor about your options.
THURMAN:
In this mandatory meeting,
a counselor
is legally obligated
to read messaging
from the state
designed to dissuade you
from getting an abortion.
GREY: And then you're off
to get your...
It's a two-visit process.
For (bleep) sake.
There's a 24-hour
waiting period.
THURMAN: Even though the law
requires women to wait 24 hours
to think about the choice
they've already made,
it's still pretty on demand.
-Oh, hey. What did you get?
-Okay.
I got some water,
some fruit snacks,
-oh, and a gun.
-Oh, cool.
Yeah, super easy to get here.
Thank God they don't have
a 24-hour waiting period.
-Right?
GREY:
And since you're far from home,
you'll need
to take time off work
and spend money on a hotel.
This looks good.
Planned Parenthood wants America
to start having more abortions
because that's liberation.
-I like this. Good choice.
-Thank you.
THURMAN:
And now it's abortion o'clock
as long as it's a Tuesday,
Wednesday or Thursday,
because those are the only days
they're able to fly in doctors
from out of state.
GREY:
Our abortion's Rob Thomas
'cause this was so smooth.
Just ask this woman,
who requested
that we conceal her identity.
She finished getting her own
super-duper easy abor...
No, it wasn't easy at all.
THURMAN:
Oh, goddamn it.
I already have four kids.
Me and my husband did not plan
to have any more kids.
Took me two weeks
to get the money together.
Within the first six
to ten weeks,
it's $600 for the procedure.
When you are ten weeks
or even a day over ten weeks,
it's $800,
and you cannot do the pill.
You can only do
the surgical procedure.
That's kind of expensive.
-Good thing everybody
in Mississippi is rich. -Yeah.
No, the majority of women here
are struggling
to, you know, make ends meet.
Everything's been stripped away
from them.
The childcare
has been stripped away,
Medicaid's been stripped away.
All of these things
are being taken away from them.
The option to have an abortion
is being taken away, also.
In talking to you right now,
it sort of sounds like
if we do want
to reduce abortions,
maybe we should have
better child welfare services.
-Comprehensive health care.
-Contraception.
-Better sex education.
-Maternity-paternity leave.
THURMAN:
Yeah.
(both laugh)
THURMAN: That's crazy.
That's doing way too much.
-Just don't have sex.
-I don't care about you
-after you're born.
-We don't care.
After you're born, it's like,
"Go on. Go on."
-Get a job.
-Yeah.
I don't... I just don't usually
talk to people
this, like, so stupid.
I'm so sorry.
GREY: If we're so stupid,
how come we're winning
and you have to deal
with crisis pregnancy centers,
closed clinics,
protesters, waiting periods,
misinformation,
and countless other laws
getting in the way
of you helping women?
THURMAN: Wow, maybe there are
a few roadblocks
to getting an abortion.
But surely there were abortions
on demand somewhere nearby.
NEWSMAN: Alabama's governor
signed into law
tough new restrictions
on abortion clinics...
NEWSMAN 2:
Louisiana has just passed
some of the strictest
abortion laws in the country.
NEWSMAN 3: Tennessee
will be building a monument
to unborn children
on state capitol grounds,
and don't even (bleep) try
going to Iowa.